>>Lukas: Mom, is it ready?
>>Mom: Yup.
>>Okey dokey.
>>Lukas: I get up five thirty in the
morning every day and I get ready
for school, takes about an hour.
My brother Rob and I jump into the
van and I go down to jazz band.
[band plays]
>>Narrator: It's zero hour,
seven AM, an hour before most
of his fellow students
show up for first period
and Lukas Bratcher is already
doing what he loves most.
>>Lukas: My school has an
outstanding music program
and I just love to play.
>>Narrator: In addition
to the jazz ensemble,
Bratcher also plays
his euphonium horn
in Mead High School's concert band.
[Lukas plays euphonium] And in
the Spokane school's award winning
marching band.
[band playing]
>>John: It's been very cool that
we've been able to make this happen,
because the marching band is set up
with stationary instruments up front,
which are typically percussion but,
but, you know, he's right down there
with them, set up with
his euphonium and is able
to play a hundred percent
of the musical show.
>>Narrator: That Lukas can
play anywhere is a testament
to his perseverance and
the support of many people
who help make his playing possible.
It has been an uphill battle ever
since he was born with a condition
that renders his limbs
nearly useless.
>>Lukas: It's called amyoplasia
arthrogryposis multiplex congenita,
and it's throughout my four limbs.
And it's basically, I have
stiffness in my joints and some
of my muscles aren't there.
>>Teacher: Well, what's another
name for one over sine theta?
>>Cosecant.
>>Cosecant theta.
>>Narrator: Lukas hasn't let
his disability prevent him
from participating fully at school.
>>Times one over cosine theta.
>>Narrator: He takes four
advanced placement classes,
and does his homework on
a laptop without the aid
of the voice recognition
software the school provided.
His daily routine includes a
session with a physical therapist
who also happens to be
Mead's football coach.
>>Lukas: I love Vic,
he's cool, he's the best.
And it's really nice 'cause
he's used to working with teams.
>>Fifty-eight, you're at one fifteen.
>>Lukas: He's used to pushing people,
so he pushes me too and it's great.
>>And time, four fourteen.
>>Narrator: A tenacious
competitor, Lukas is captain
of a winning chess team he
helped start at the school.
>>I like that pawn.
>>You can keep it?
>>No.
>>James: He likes to win, but he's
a good sport when he doesn't win.
I think he likes the game, he likes
the fight, but he always seems
to have something positive.
>>Lukas: What can I
learn from this loss?
>>Narrator: Lacking manual dexterity,
Lukas learned to play music his
own special way, to the amazement
of his first band director.
>>Lee: He looked very eager and
excited about being a member
of the band, and quite honestly,
my thought at that time was,
"Oh my goodness, how
could this possibly work?"
And as we took the students
through their method book,
I noticed that occasionally,
he would play on his horn.
His hands were not able to activate
the valves on the instrument,
so it was apparent to me that what
he was doing was just being selective
about the notes that he was playing.
He was willing to sit there and just
wait for that one note to come along
in the music, and when it came,
he played it with all of his heart
and enthusiasm and capability to
make the best sound that he could.
That was enough for him, initially.
>>Narrator: But Lukas
knew he could do more,
and that's when serendipity
led his mother
to the instrument repair
shop of Robin Amend.
>>Robin: I love repair, I mean, it's
always different, always working
on a different instrument.
There's always different problems.
My grandfather was a
Vaudeville musician.
He lost his arm in a
lumber mill accident.
He put an ad in the Portland
paper asking one armed people
if they were interested
in learning music.
He taught them how
to play instruments.
>>Narrator: The senior Amend also
patented a device that allowed people
with missing hands to play the piano.
>>Robin: I'd always wished
that I could make something
that could make a person who had
lost an arm be able to take the place
of their fingers, and then one night,
I woke up in the middle of the night
and I realized that
joysticks aren't just
for putting electrical
things on screens.
Joysticks can do other things.
Joysticks can do mechanical things.
>>Narrator: Amend's dream became
a small box with a joystick
that triggered solenoids and
operated the valves of a horn.
Learning a new way of playing
was exhilarating and frustrating
for Lukas, and just as
he was getting the hang
of playing it, someone took his horn.
>>Newscaster: Call crime check
if you have any information.
That number is--
>>Kristy: It was stolen in the
morning and by five o'clock
that same day, I was getting
the first call in my cell phone
from an anonymous person
that said that they wanted
to contribute monetarily to a fund
to either replace it,
or as a reward for it.
And from that point
on, it just snowballed
into this huge wonderful thing
where the community raised
six thousand dollars.
>>Andrew: You know, I wasn't
quite sure where the optimum spot
for the solenoids was gonna
be, so I wanted to be able
to have it slide up and down in--
>>Narrator: The loss of the
first horn became a blessing
when mechanical engineer
Andrew Coleman joined Amend
to design a second,
more responsive joystick
and horn, which Lukas uses today.
[band plays]
>>Kristy: What's so beautiful with
this whole music thing is, you know,
he's a part of that whole
huge sound that they do.
They look at him and he's
as good or better or,
you know, as anybody else there.
[ band plays Sugar-plum Fairy ]
>>Terry: It's very
unique what he does.
There are some musical
challenges, but it's his personality
that is making it happen, 'cause
he's taking all those pieces
and put them together in a positive
way and working really hard.
>>Lee: When I heard and saw Lukas
perform recently at a concert,
it reminded me just
how far we've come.
And through the efforts of all
the people that have been involved
in supporting him, we
caught on to his dream.
>>[band plays Sugar-plum Fairy]
>>Lukas: I'm hoping to go to
college on a music scholarship
and study music and be a musician.
I love to play.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org